>> Announcer: From the Library
of Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Nicholas: Good evening,
ladies and gentlemen.
Welcome to the Library of Congress.
My name is Nicholas Brown.
I'm a music specialist
in the Music Division.
Very pleased to introduce
you to Steven Isserlis.
[Applause] Steven is, of course,
one of the world's great cellists
and he's a British extraction,
and we are very pleased
to have him return
here to the Library.
He's performed here
several times including
at the living legend
award presentation
to Marta Casals Istomin pretty
recently, and he's also a mainstay
on the DC concert circuit whether
he's with Washington Performing Arts
or Kennedy Center or
here at the Library.
You have proven to him that
you love him, so we're pleased
to capitalize upon that tonight.
So we're just going to have an
informal chat here from Steven
about his experience with the
repertoire that's being performed
today, also about his time at the
Library, and then we'll open it
up to your questions, and Steven,
what has your day been like?
I know you had a chance to see
some of our manuscripts earlier.
Can you share some
thoughts about those?
>> Steven: No.
[Laughter]
>> Nicholas: Okay.
>> Steven: No, they were wonderful.
They were wonderful.
Some interesting cello music, Karini
and some other less known figures.
That was interesting,
but, of course,
I suppose the highlight
was the Schelomo by Bloch.
It's lovely to touch, but
the best thing was the Brahms
and Schumann manuscripts,
and they touched this paper.
They wrote on this paper.
It's like being in
touch with the gods,
and somebody was standing there who
works here says, "It never fails
for us, that feeling, as well.
It never lessens."
So that was exciting.
>> Nicholas: Were there any-
>> Steven: And I had a roast
beef sandwich for lunch.
[Laughter]
>> Nicholas: Very good.
Were there any kind of insights
in the scores and manuscripts
that you saw in terms of
things that are different
in the published editions?
>> Steven: No.
I noticed there wasn't at all in the
Bloch, the piece I've played most.
What is very hard to
read, the Schumann,
but that was very interesting
because the piece they showed
me was the [inaudible] piece,
which I have actually played in
the Piatti arrangement for cello,
[inaudible], and so
many crossings out.
There's almost another piece there.
I'd love to have a really sort
of true Schumann scholar go
through that and make a new edition
because that would be
very interesting, I think.
>> Nicholas: Speaking of scholars,
you have written a recent
book, correct, on Schumann?
>> Steven: "Correct on
Schumann," it is not called.
No. [Laughter] Yes, I have, but
they're not speaking of scholars
because I'm not a scholar.
I'm just an enthusiast, and, yeah,
it's coming out in
America, which is nice.
September.
It's basically-Schumann wrote,
he wrote a book of advice
for young musicians, and I read
it many times over the years, and,
well, a few times over the years,
and thought it was very nice.
Lovely, of course,
Schumann, but it sort of--
I started writing little bits
of advice for young musicians
on my sort of official
Facebook page,
and I was amazed by the response.
I mean, I just wrote something
on the train last week, and I,
over 1400 people liked
it or whatever.
I mean they, musicians, young
musicians are really eager
for advice, and I think some of
them don't get it, I have to say.
So, of course, what Schumann
says makes such perfect sense,
but it was in a very antiquated
translation, and also he's speaking
to a sort of person
who hardly exists now.
So, what I did, I sort
of-it said, "Revisit."
The title is "Robert
Schumann's Advice
for the Young Musicians
Revisited," by Steven Isserlis,
and I sort of just
updated everything I could.
It's a huge commentary.
I suppose 75 percent of the
book is by me commentating
on Schumann's wisdom and just
sort of making it, I hope,
more relevant for what we call
the YouTube generation, and just,
you know, trying to
reinforce his message in a way
that I hope young musicians today
and all the musicians
might understand.
>> Nicholas: Are there any specific
themes in his overall message?
>> Steven: Well, it's-I
mean, I suppose what shines
through the book most is his
absolute deep, pure love of music,
and that's what I try and reinforce
and say it's not about the career.
It's not about being a success.
It's not that.
It's about the music.
You just have to love music
and never let go of that, and,
of course, many more specific
things, but that is, I think,
the overriding message that I got
from my teachers over the years
and I get from Schumann,
and I try and pass on.
>> Nicholas: You've also
written some other books.
>> Steven: I have.
>> Nicholas: Can you
share those with us?
>> Steven: No.
No. [Laughter] All right.
Mind you, you did promise me a
cup of tea, which has not arrived,
which for an Englishman is torture.
>> Nicholas: I know.
I'm sorry.
>> Steven: Trying to convince myself
that it's actually the afternoon
still even though I just called my
girlfriend in England, and
she was falling asleep.
It wasn't a good reminder for my
body, but actually it's midnight.
Yeah, I wrote two books for children
and which have actually never
have been published in America,
although one could get them here,
and one is called "Why
Beethoven Threw the Stew,"
and the other is called "Why
Handel Waggled His Wig,"
and they're both books
are about six composers,
and it's just really telling the
lives of the composers for children
but trying to do it as
accurately as I can, as I could.
They were originally written
for my son, I suppose,
but then it became something
bigger and just, you know,
without distorting the facts.
You don't have to.
Composers were such
fascinating people
who had such fascinating lives.
You don't have to exaggerate
or distort or fantasize.
It's all there.
They had amazing lives, and,
you know, one of my purposes is
to introduce to get the children
interested in these people
and therefore in their
music, and, as I say to them,
they'll have friends for life.
You know, great music
never lets you down.
It can always be with you
no matter where you are,
no matter what's going
on in your life,
if you have music,
it's a life saver.
>> Nicholas: Are there any specific
masterworks that you reference
in those books for the children?
>> Steven: Well, you-it's
sort of made up, first of all,
I do the life, and I do
specific, there's another thing
where there's little bite
sized stories from their life,
and then there's a little bit
about the music at the end,
and I suggest what
the children might
like to listen to,
and I was very happy.
Once in Cleveland, Ohio,
somebody came up to me and said,
"Every night we listen to one
of the pieces you recommend."
I thought, "Yes, that's
what I want."
>> Nicholas: Awesome.
>> Steven: Awesome.
>> Nicholas: I'm from Boston.
Sorry.
>> Steven: Oh, don't worry.
My son went to the
American School in London.
Then he went to the
university over here.
I hear the word "awesome" a
lot, but it's a nice word.
It's positive.
It's better than "like."
I hear that as well.
I was in a taxi today, and
it said "rate you ride."
Isn't that "rate your ride?"
>> Nicholas: Well, they
probably gave up and were
like this way they can't
say it's the wrong "your."
[Laughter]
>> Steven: I guess.
Interesting point of view.
>> Nicholas: Optimism, somehow.
I don't know.
Too long in the government.
Awesome. The repertoire
this evening.
>> Steven: Yes.
>> Nicholas: What are
your thoughts on kind
of the connections
between the works?
>> Steven: Well, if I'm honest,
there are fewer connections
than I would have liked.
I did originally offer a
program all from Paris,
and you said you already
had two of the pieces,
so we couldn't play them.
Not placing blame anywhere.
[Laughter] However, for the rest of
the tour, which is like two weeks,
we're doing a Parisian-based
program, but it's slightly sort
of watered down tonight in
that way only by the fact
that we're including Shostakovich's
sonata because we did just play it
in Belgium a couple of weeks ago.
So that's what we start.
Anyway, it's a masterpiece.
I have no objection, but it does
take the central sort of theme
of the program away, but
then, you know, Shostakovich
and Martinu together
within ten years--
actually within about
five years of each other.
So that I think has gotten an
interesting sort of mixture,
and Shostakovich, which is much more
ironic and Martinu knew much more,
sort of, all out dramatic
and traumatized.
I mean, Martinu's sonata
was written at a time
when his homeland was being
overrun by the Nazis, and also,
which I only discovered
comparatively recently,
when he was having a torrid
affair with his gorgeous student,
Kapralova or [inaudible].
I don't know which, and he was about
to run away to America with her.
I didn't know that until after I'd
recorded the sonatas, [inaudible].
At least I got to write
it in the sleeve notes.
So I think both outwardly and
inwardly, Martinu was having
such a traumatic time, and you
really feel it in the sonata.
I think it's an incredible
master-They're both incredible
masterpieces, and then
after the interval,
we do two very little
pieces by Renaldo Hahn,
but I find them charming.
They're called "Improvisations
on Irish Melodies."
I wouldn't have called
them improvisations.
They're really just settings
of the Irish melodies,
but I love Renaldo Hahn.
He's sort of mostly remembered now
because he was Marcel
Proust's boyfriend,
but he was a lovely composer.
In fact, Jeremy Dink, with whom I
played when I first played here,
he introduced me to the
music of Renaldo Hahn.
It's wonderful.
It has just actually
been republished,
this and his variations for cello.
I wrote the introduction for it.
It's, you know, as I said, it's
really tiny, but it's lovely,
and there and for me
the greatest, well,
one of the two greatest
twentieth century cellists
and artists we're playing.
It's by Faure.
Gabriel Faure is number two.
You're not going to ask
me what the other one is.
>> Nicholas: [inaudible]
>> Steven: Yeah, [inaudible]
is number one.
Faure, I'm an absolute
Faure nut myself.
He's named Gabriel partly
because of Faure and, you know,
Faure I just think is underrated
and these sonatas are not often
played still, and for me they are,
you know, of course, I love
the pieces in the first two.
I adore them, Martinu and
Shostakovich, but Faure is just
on the highest level of music
for me, the second sonata.
I hope we can convince
you tonight of that,
and actually Marta
Casals is coming tonight
and I had dinner with
her last night.
I said, "Your husband
didn't play sonatas."
She said, "Yes, he did."
"I don't think so," I said,
and she looked very guilty
as well she might even though
she wasn't anywhere near born
at the time he might
have played them.
I think that is astonishing.
His music never touches the ground.
He was completely frail, old,
stone deaf when he wrote them,
and yet his music just
flies in the air.
It's got this ecstatic feel, and
the slow movement is gorgeous.
It was originally written actually
for Windburn to mark the centurial
of Napoleon's death, but it
goes beautifully on the cello.
It's a bit like his famous
eulogy for cello, but to me,
much more moving because it's
got more contrast and it's more
of a-even more of a
story to it, I think.
I just-this music, I play Faure
sonatas as often as I possibly can
because it's like a mission
for me to convince people.
So don't worry.
People can be honest with
me afterwards and tell me
that they don't like them,
but I'll just commit suicide,
but don't feel bad about it.
[Laughter] And then finally we
finish with Mr. [inaudible] piece,
which I'll probably introduce
from the stage because I quite
like doing that, and that also
is an extraordinary piece,
and the Paris connection
there is, that last move,
is the can-can, can-can macabre.
He's amazing, Tom.
I mean he just-he takes
things from everywhere.
He adores Faure like I do.
I thought that was one of
the first bonds between us.
That's partly why we became
friends because of our love of,
shared love of a late
Faure, but he takes it
from everywhere-[inaudible],
Janocek,
from jazz, from pop, everything.
He'll take anything, and it
comes out as his own language,
and that's an extraordinary
gift for a composer.
I think he just got it.
Some people have it,
and he does, I feel.
>> Nicholas: Is his musical
voice the same as operas
versus his instrumental
chamber music?
>> Steven: It's not the
same, but there are elements.
There's definitely shared DNA.
I haven't heard-of course, the
new opera premiers in London.
I know was in Salzburg already,
but it premiers the night we
play his piece in San Francisco.
So, of course, I can't go.
I was just offered half
price tickets for it
in London, and I can't go to them.
I'm suffering deeply.
[Laughter]
>> Nicholas: Great.
What would be one of the
musical surprises this evening?
Is there a moment in any of the
pieces that we should all-- ?
>> Steven: I could get lost, or
like you're playing incredibly
out of tune, or maybe
that's not a surprise.
I don't know.
Well, I think every piece actually.
I mean there's only
really one famous piece
on the program, which
is Shostakovich.
I mean, when I say famous, I
mean played very, very often,
and that's the first piece.
So I think for most people here,
I'm probably right in saying
that they'll be least-Well,
I don't believe anybody
who tells me they've
heard the Renaldo Hahn
because I think it's only been
played once in the past, you know,
75 years, and that was by me,
and I made a wrong entrance.
So it hasn't really been played.
So tonight's sort of the premier.
>> Nicholas: Yeah, there you go.
Earlier you were mentioning
your-some thoughts
about the relationship
between artists, the audience,
and the industry, that kind of
thing, and some opportunities
for growth in the musical community.
>> Steven: I was?
>> Nicholas: Yes.
>> Steven: What did I say?
>> Nicholas: You said that
we need more listeners.
>> Steven: Ah, we do.
No, I mean, I said we need more
listeners than we do players.
That's true.
I see, in that other interview.
Yes, that's right.
We do. We need a thousand listeners
for every one player really
or one soloist anyway, and yes,
I mean, it's a-I also said-
and I say this repeatedly
in the book.
It's not about being a soloist
because I don't consider
myself particularly a soloist.
I consider myself a chamber
music player, and I play a lot
of concertos because, you
know, and that is chamber music
on a large scale, and that's what
I encourage all the people who pass
through my evil hands to consider
themselves, you know, you know,
and my sort of younger
brother, Joshua Bell,
he also considers himself
a chamber music player.
I mean it's just you have
to play louder, of course,
when you play with orchestra,
but it's still the same thing.
It's passing from one
voice to another.
It's conversation, and that goes
all through music, and yeah,
I also said that some of the
greatest musicians I know,
in fact a lot of them,
are not soloists.
They're teachers.
They're in orchestras.
They're a chamber music
player, you know,
as in an established chamber
ensemble, and even listeners,
some listeners I know who
understand so much about music,
actually even Connie, Connie Shih,
the pianist I'm playing with,
she's got this adorable
6-year-old daughter, Amalie,
and she was listening to the
rehearsal today as she often does.
There's no babysitter.
She just sat on the stage
and did some things,
and then with her hands she was
describing the music we were
playing perfectly.
You know, it's not about career.
It's not about anything.
It's about music.
>> Nicholas: So if you
were approaching someone
who has never stepped
into an art music concert,
how would you engage them and
try and get them in the door?
>> Steven: Well, I wouldn't
call it art music for sure.
>> Nicholas: Well, classical.
We're trying to move
on from that one.
>> Steven: No, no.
>> Nicholas: Good music.
How about that?
>> Steven: I'd say you're going
to hear stories basically,
I mean, especially.
Actually, it's a good thing to start
with a Shostakovich because it's
like a ballad, the first
particularly, but the whole piece,
it's like a collection of stories,
and I mean that actually
goes for every piece tonight.
Perhaps in a way the Faure a little
bit less, but it's different.
It's more sort of a portrait of
nature, the [inaudible] ones, but,
yeah, I would say you're
going to hear humor
or you're going to hear drama.
You're going to hear
exquisite beauty.
I mean in the music, not
the playing, I would say,
and you're going to hear a range
of voices telling you this
very, very different story.
>> Nicholas: Do you have any
upcoming recording projects?
>> Steven: I've got a recording
coming out of Haydn concertos,
which is the first time I've
ever directed an orchestra
for a recording.
So I hope that's all right.
[Inaudible] orchestra
and Haydn and CP Bach,
I just think extraordinary piece,
and then little pieces
by Bacharini and Mozart.
So I hope that's coming out.
That's the next one to come out, and
then I've got with Connie actually,
first recording with Connie,
with whom I do more concerts
with than any other pianist.
We, I think probably next year
we've got a recording coming
out of First World War music
and including some little items
at the end, which I
played on a trench cello,
which is this little box.
I think it's called a
holiday cello originally,
and then this soldier took it
into the trenches and played it,
and there's an inscription inside
from a famous poet whose
name I always forget.
It wasn't [inaudible].
It wasn't [inaudible], and
it wasn't Rufus Wainwright.
It was somebody.
[Laughter] One of those
First World War figures,
and it's this beautiful
little sound.
A friend of mine, Charles
Baer, who I'm sure you know
because he's the world's leading
expert on string instruments,
he just told me about this thing.
I said "I've got to see it," and
I went and tried it and this sad,
soft little sound came
out, and I loved it,
and so I thought I'd record on it.
So we're doing normal, first of
all, more rapid Frank Bridge,
Debbie [inaudible], Veburn,
and Faure Number One,
and then four little pieces like our
First World War pops, popular song,
and a hymn, and "The Swan."
That was quite ambitious
for this little cello,
but I haven't heard it yet.
I hope it comes off because
it's lovely, this little thing.
>> Nicholas: Neat.
We actually just opened a big First
World War exhibit, which has a lot
of items from both
the music collections,
more on the American side.
So like "Over There,"
the George Cohan song,
and even a German soldier's
helmet, which is kind of intense,
and propaganda posters
and that kind of deal.
So I encourage all
of you to check it
out upstairs during
the regular hours,
and we also have a
wonderful digital presentation
of the exhibit including
some footage
from World War I, video footage.
>> Steven: Prepare us for
the upcoming World War III.
[Laughter] Sorry.
I don't mean to cast a
pawl on this evening.
>> Nicholas: On that note, we
will open it up to Q and A.
So if you have a question
for Steven,
if you wouldn't mind just raising
your hand, and my colleague, Jay,
will bring a microphone to you.
>> Audience: Hi, Steven.
>> Steven: Hi.
>> Audience: So I was wondering
when you are approaching a piece
for the first time
and say it's something
with piano or-I don't know how
if you're a piano player as well,
but how do you study
the classical scene?
So I always have this problem of-I
focused on my part, but then I kind
of forget what's going
on at the piano,
and a lot of your musical
advice, I think, to all musicians,
and you're always emphasizing that
like the story that's going back
and forth between those things.
So I was wondering how you if
you're coming into something cold,
how you kind of integrate
kind of both voices?
>> Steven: Well, I deal
with that in the book.
I say that every musician
really should play the piano
because you have to
know the whole score.
You have to know the
piano part and, you know,
how ever many parts there are,
you have to know them all.
Otherwise you're like an actor
only knowing one part in a play,
and so you're not going
to get the story.
So, yeah, I work a lot at the piano.
It takes me hours often.
I just play, and it
makes such a difference.
Well, it makes all the difference.
I couldn't really learn
a piece without.
Occasionally if it's a
[inaudible] modern score
and it's just too complicated,
then I unwillingly have to listen
to a recording, but
I'd much rather not.
But no, absolutely.
Go to the piano with songs.
Absolutely, go to the piano.
Yeah. Understand the harmonies
because that's what the
composer was thinking about,
and ask yourself first of
all what has he written?
You need a good edition always,
and that makes a huge difference,
and then why has he
written or she written it,
written it, written that?
Every marking there's a reason.
The composer's hands don't just
twitch and they write a piano
or an [inaudible] or
an accent or whatever.
They mean it, and, yes, it's fun
to get the sort of little messages
from the gentleman behind the
screen there, Mr. Beethoven.
Hundreds of years.
Every marking he puts
makes such a difference
if you actually look at it.
Try to think what he wrote.
As my friend Olli Mustonen
says, "These are messages
from one good musician to
another," and I like that.
He also came out with
a great-Oh, yes.
[Applause] Thank you.
It's got whiskey in it.
[Laughter] Yeah, Olli also
came out with a brilliant thing
which I hadn't thought of.
He said, "People who say they're
scared to come to classical concerts
because they don't know enough about
it are like people who are scared
to go for a walk in the forest
because they don't know enough
about botany," which
I think is great.
I love that.
That was slightly off topic,
but anyway, so the piano.
Yeah, everybody should
play the piano.
I play the piano very badly
but enough for my purposes.
>> Audience: Could you tell us
something about your instrument?
>> Steven: Yeah, the instrument I'll
be playing tonight is the Marquis de
Corboron Stradivarius of 1726, which
was owned for all of her career
by Zara Nelsova, and so she
probably played here, I presume.
>> Nicholas: Probably.
>> Steven: [Inaudible]
Yeah, it's my great uncle.
[Laughter] No, I love
this instrument.
You know, it's not the
only instrument I play.
For some music because
I have, of course,
my beloved old style gut
strings on it, which are perfect
for most music, I think, including
Shostakovich, which, of course,
would have been written
for gut strings.
The Shostakovich sonata, but
if I really want steel strings,
which is as it sounds,
a harder steely sound,
then I have another cello that
I have with steel strings on it,
but this is the cello I use
most because it's an aristocrat.
[ Inaudible question ]
First question, I can't think
of a better expression
than classical music.
It's very limited, but I think
it's probably less off putting
than art music.
I don't know.
Of course, nowadays the
boundaries are blurred anyway,
but I mean I'd love it if somebody
came out with a better expression.
I mean, art music.
It could-I think that
sounds a bit precious.
I think classical music is
slightly better than that,
but it's not perfect, and as
for women composers, well,
there are now many
wonderful women composers.
In the past I think
it was a social thing
that they were discouraged
from studying it.
They were discouraged from
performing, and through performing,
of course, you became
more confident.
You tried things out.
They were discouraged from playing
with famous people, you know,
because they couldn't perform.
They couldn't play
with famous people
who could have influenced them well.
So I don't-- I can't think
of any great women composers.
I know some fine ones.
I think Laura Schumann
wrote beautiful music.
Fanny Mendelssohn, too, and of
course in the past, Hilda Bingen
and Chaminade, and there
are a few actually.
French ones who wrote some
really beautiful music,
but I think it's changed finally
or it's changing very much now,
finally, as it is with conductors,
and now finally we're getting
some really great women conductors
and composers just
because of social things.
There were always great women
players, I think, but, again,
they were-we don't hear so
much about them, you know,
history books because they were
discouraged from performing so much,
and that's just an
unfortunate fact of history.
I would have loved to have
heard [inaudible], for instance,
who only played so beautifully than
she who didn't write the Sicilian,
which is her most famous
piece, but she didn't write it,
but I think you hear a few
descriptions of people,
but they played in private.
So I think that's the reason, but
it's-I'm glad things have changed,
and certainly, you know, I think
isn't it 50/50 now with players?
And soon will be with
conductors and composers, I think.
>> Audience: One of the very
best concerts I have attended
in the past few seasons was the
one that you and Robert Levin did
of Beethoven music at the
Kennedy Center a few seasons back
with Robert at forte
piano, and then, of course,
you issued a wonderful CD
set with all the cello music.
I was just wondering-
>> Steven: I like you.
>> Audience: If you and he have
discussed doing any other repertoire
with forte piano accompaniment
because it was just so wonderful.
>> Steven: Thank you.
Yeah, we have a bit,
but then, I don't know.
It's just endless.
I think that's my-if I had to
choose one favorite thing I do
in concerts these days, it's that
cycle where we do the whole cycle
with forte piano, and I sort
of don't feel like moving
on because I just, I want to do
it again and again and again, but,
having said that, last Saturday,
the week before, I gave a recital
at [inaudible] on an 1847
Stryker piano, and we did Chopin
and friends, and that was
a beautiful instrument,
and I love to do a Mendelsohn
with that instrument.
I love to do Schumann with
that instrument, Chopin.
Hopefully later this year we're
recording the Chopin sonata
with Chopin's own piano, one
of his players, and so yeah,
and then in fact the next
year I'm going to come back
to Washington the harpsichord
with Richard Egarr,
who I think is wonderful.
He's great.
I remember once in the rehearsal,
I said, "It would be nice
to have a crescendo here
on the rising sequence,
but you can't do it.
You can't do it because you're
on the harpsichord, can you?"
And he took me and said a word
I won't repeat here, [laughter]
and he did a crescendo
on the harpsichord.
I still don't know how he did it.
I remember I asked him this
recent, "How did you do that?"
He said, "You have
to believe in it."
[Laughter] It's like Schroder with
his black keys just painted on.
>> Nicholas: We had
Richard here in January.
He did a recital, which
was really spectacular.
>> Steven: He's a good lad.
He's fun company, too.
That is very important when you
travel with people, you know.
I travel with Joshua.
I travel with Connie and Amalie,
whom as you see I adore, and Bob.
Bob, who, I mean, he's
just a fount of knowledge.
I've asked him to leave
me his brain in his will.
[Laughter] I do have to
say a rather naughty story.
I adore him.
He's amazing, but his facts pour.
I think he wakes up at 7:00 in the
morning and facts start pouring
out of him, and then we had
been touring for two weeks,
and then the orchestra,
the Age of Enlightenment
in London advertised this talk
he was giving to raise funds
for the orchestra, and they
charged 1000 pounds for a seat just
for a talk, and they sold out,
and I said, "God, that's amazing
because I would actually
pay 1000 pounds
at this point to stop him talking."
[Laughter] That's said
with great love.
>> Nicholas: Just one
second for the microphone.
>> Audience: Last month we had a
wonderful symposium in Washington
on Shostakovich and Vineberg.
>> Steven: Oh, yes.
>> Audience: Vineberg wrote a
lot of music for Rostropovich,
and I was just wondering, he's
a good composer to most of us.
Are you familiar with
him, and if you are,
do you make recommendations?
>> Steven: Well, I've never
played any, but I'm friends
with Gidon Kramer, and I don't
think Gidon plays anything other
than Vineberg these days.
He's obsessed with him.
So I've heard him play a lot of it.
It is very fine music, isn't it?
And whether it's as great as
Shostakovich, I'm not yet convinced,
but now I was sort of thinking.
My friend, I've got an
Armenian cellist friend called
Alexander Chaushian.
He said, "You must learn it.
You must learn it."
I said, "Well, you play it,"
and in fact he has recorded
it, excellently, I'm sure.
Yeah, I'm always-my
completely unknown composer,
actually I haven't
played him for years,
but I'm going to again,
is Carl Fruhling.
Very different kettle of fish, but
he was a-oh, he lived in Vienna
for most of his life, and
he's sort of post-Brahms.
We recorded with Michael
Collins and Steve Huff years ago,
we recorded his clarinet chair,
and it's a gorgeous piece.
I mean, nothing to do with Vineberg.
Sorry. Just going on unusual
composers, unknown composers,
and such touching music, Fruhling,
but Vineberg, yeah, he's major
and I'm pleased he's got such a
sort of resurgence, and of course I
like to play contemporary
music occasionally
because I love working
with composers.
Of course, I've worked
with Tom Ades.
I've worked a lot with Kurtag.
I just premiered a new piece
by Kurtag, but, oh, sorry,
but with different composers
such as John Tavener and hoping
to do a recording of John's
late works, and, yeah,
but it's absolutely it's great that
Gidon has this mission for Vineberg
like I do for Faure, but anyway.
>> Audience: You so beautifully
expressed your sentiments
of the music speaks for itself
and it's all about the music.
>> Steven: It is.
>> Audience: What's your sentiments
about the showmanship that has kind
of crept in in the
last 20 or 30 years?
>> Steven: I don't mind people's-I
think people's emotions will show
on their face, but
it's, to me, so obvious.
So often it's just fake.
I like to feel something
comes from deep,
deep inside like when I
hear Radu Lupu for instance,
just to pluck one name out of the
hat, but he's a very extreme example
of somebody that music
comes from deep inside.
Of course, it shows on his face,
but he's not putting anything on.
It's absolutely genuine,
and that's fine.
You know, I-showmanship
in itself is not bad.
Some music is showman
like, and that's fine,
but it's got to be genuine, and I
think so much now is not genuine.
I can't imagine [inaudible] sort of
throwing himself around the stage,
or, you know, when every time
I play here, I think Segeti
and [inaudible] played here.
That's one of the great
recordings of all time.
I bet they didn't throw
themselves around the stage,
and they didn't pose for record
covers in bikinis and things.
I just don't think so.
[Laughter] So, yeah, I think it's,
there is a little bit-I refuse
to use the two words "music"
and "business" together,
but I'm not fond of the times
when they are used together.
>> Nicholas: Last question
over here.
>> Steven: I should practice.
>> Audience: Could you tell us three
or four of your desert island disks?
>> Steven: Well, I did
desert island disks.
I'll tell you all eight
that I chose,
which I wouldn't change
now, of course.
There are only eight.
Should be thousands.
Schubert Fantasia in F
Minor for Piano Duet,
[inaudible] Lupu, and
then what do I have?
The Beethoven the Late
Quartets, which is shocking.
I really don't know that well,
played by the Bush Quartet, Faure,
of course, Choral Pieces sung
by the Chorale Gabriel Faure,
Schumann's Symphonies,
conducted by [inaudible].
What was the fifth classical
one, or is that five?
Of course, "St. Matthew Passion."
That was my one I would take, and
then I had three other records.
"The Importance of Being
Hoffnung," which is a series
of interviews he gave
with Charles Richardson,
which is one of the funniest-it is
the funniest record I've ever heard
and then Monty Python.
One of their songs actually, "I'm
so Worried," was the one I chose
by my friend Terry Jones, and
then the last one was a tribute
to my son.
It was "I'm Only Sleeping"
by the Beatles,
which was a rather
pointed tribute to my son.
I would still choose the same,
still dedicate it to my son.
Yes.
>> Nicholas: Which recording
of the St. Matthew Passion?
>> Steven: Well, it
was by my friend,
Philippe Herreweghe, Herreweghe.
I don't know.
I'm still to be convinced
by-completely by anyone recording.
I think there are many
wonderful recordings.
Nowadays I think I'd
probably choose [inaudible].
I'm going straight back
from this tour to play
for his seventieth birthday.
I think I'd choose the
recording by John Butt,
who is a fantastic musician
and a great friend of mine,
and he's an alive,
genuine, wonderful musician.
So I think I would choose his now.
>> Nicholas: Great.
He's fantastic.
>> Steven: He's great,
and he's completely mad,
completely mad, but he's wonderful.
[Laughter]
>> Nicholas: If you've never
read any of his scholarship
on Butt, go out and Google that.
It's pretty interesting.
Wonderful.
So thank you, Steven, for joining
us in here, and before we go,
I just want to let everyone know
that Steven will kindly be signing
CDs following the conclusion
of the concert.
Our colleague, Andresh, will be
making some merchandise available
for you when you go
into the concert.
So feel free to stop by and check
that out, and we will look forward
to seeing you at 8:00
in the Coolidge.
Thanks for being here for a
Library of Congress concert.
How many are here for
the first time ever?
Awesome. Welcome.
Yes, I know.
I had to get-see, bookends,
just like a crowd.
There you go.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, Steven, and
we'll see you soon.
[Applause]
>> Announcer: This has
been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.